[ Heart beating ]
[ Eerie music plays ]
♪♪
-Hello, Jimmy.
-Come play with us.
-Come play with us, Jimmy.
-Forever and ever.
-And ever, and ever.
♪♪
-Okay.
What should we do?
-Want to help us
pick paint colors?
-Sure.
-And murder Higgins?
-You bet.
-This one's called "redrum."
-Ooh, nice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-From Studio 6B
in Rockefeller Center
in the heart of New York City,
it's "The Tonight Show
starring Jimmy Fallon."
-♪ Hey, hey hey, hey ♪
-Tonight,
join Jimmy and his guests...
Musical guest...
And featuring the legendary
Roots crew.
-1775.
-And now, here he is,
Jimmy Fallon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hey, come on.
Guys...
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
Oh, that's very nice.
I appreciate that.
Thank you very much.
Hey!
Welcome!
Nice to see you!
Nice to see you.
Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome, welcome, welcome!
-♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh ♪
-Oh, my goodness.
Enjoy yourself.
Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
You have made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
Well, guys, everyone
is talking about this --
early this morning, all flights
across the U.S. were grounded
due to a failure with the FAA's
computer system.
Yeah.
Zero flights took off,
but somehow everyone's luggage
still ended up in Pittsburgh.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
No flights took off.
It's never a good sign
when you see a jumbo jet
taking the I-95 to Tampa.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
It's never fun
being stuck in an airport.
Families headed to Disney
told their kids
the luggage carousel was the
"It's a Small World" ride.
They're like, "Just calm down
and sit next to the Tumi bag.
I'll take your picture."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, no one could fix
the computer glitch.
One guy at the FAA said,
"I don't know.
Maybe unplug it,
plug it back in?
I don't know."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, the outage happened
while some planes
were in the air.
If there's one thing you don't
want to hear from your pilot,
it's "Attention, passengers --
do yourselves a favor
and stay off Twitter
for a little bit."
[ Laughter ]
Thankfully, no one flying on
JetBlue could see the news,
'cause all the TVs were broken.
But I mean, that's --
[ Laughter ]
Wouldn't it be great
if all this actually started
'cause some guy
didn't put his phone
on airplane mode during takeoff?
[ Laughter ]
"It's real?
This does something?"
Of course, people were upset
about all the flight delays.
Well, today, several airlines
made a statement
about the outage.
For instance, Delta said...
[ Laughter ]
United said...
Southwest was like...
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah."
And American Airlines said...
And Southwest continued...
Then JetBlue said...
And finally Southwest said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Windows 95?
-Wow.
-Well, hey, listen to this.
There was a report that the
Biden administration was
considering a ban on gas stoves.
I don't know
if you read about this.
Well, after backlash
from both parties,
President Biden said that he is
not in favor of the idea.
People stuck at airports
have said,
"I've been at JFK for nine
hours, but, by all means,
continue this
important discussion
about gas freaking stoves!"
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Biden said,
"You can keep your gas stove,
but you have to wear an N95
while you use it."
[ Laughter ]
Some more political news --
today, New York Republicans
called on Congressman
George Santos to resign,
and Santos responded,
saying he won't.
But since it's Santos,
that means he will, maybe.
[ Laughter ]
Santos said he's not a quitter,
and he proved it
at the '92 Olympics,
where he won five gold medals.
[ Laughter ]
Well, get this,
after all the excitement
over the speaker of the house
votes,
C-SPAN wants to add
additional cameras
in the chamber
so that it can cover
more than just special events.
They even released this message.
Take a look at this.
-We here at C-SPAN are excited
to bring you even more coverage
by adding additional cameras
to the chambers,
including shots of the podiums,
shots of the House
and Senate leaders,
and even a camera
in Bernie Sanders' eyebrows.
-The price of Moderna
is too damn high!
[ Applause ]
-"The new Netflix"?
I don't know.
Some entertainment news --
Coachella just announced
all the artists performing
at this year's festival.
And this is nice.
[ Cheers ]
Yeah, they even went ahead
and paired each band
with a perfect edible.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right, Coachella just
released this year's lineup,
but it seems like
they took the name Coachella
a bit more literal this year.
Watch this.
-Coachella is back,
and we've got an incredible
lineup this year,
including Bad Bunny,
Frank Ocean, Blackpink,
Andy Reid, Pete Carroll,
Mike McCarthy, Phil Jackson,
Mike Krzyzewski, Bill Belichick,
and America's favorite coach,
Craig T. Nelson.
[ Air horns ]
Coachella.
Don't miss it.
-Just -- I find that --
I'll see Craig T. Nelson.
-Yeah.
-I'm down.
Switching gears.
While the cost of other food
has declined in recent months,
the price of eggs
still remain extremely high.
Now when you order eggs
in a diner, the waiter's like,
"Get a load of Jeff Bezos
over here."
[ Laughter ]
"Mr. Three Eggs.
Must be nice, hey."
[ Laughter ]
"Must be -- Must be nice with
those three eggs, this guy.
Oh, wow."
[ Laughter ]
It's hard finding cheap eggs.
This morning, I bought
a spinach and feta omelet
out of the trunk
of some guy's car.
-Really?
-Yeah.
Meanwhile, I saw that Guinness
just announced
that they're raising the price
of a pint in Ireland.
-Ooh.
-One politician suggested
drinking water instead.
And doctors say he should be out
of the hospital by Sunday.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of beverages,
Pepsi is replacing Sierra Mist
with a new drink
to compete with Sprite,
and it is called Starry.
Here's what it looks like.
Yeah.
It's called Starry,
and just like Sierra Mist,
it's lemon-lime flavored
and sounds like it was named
after a stripper.
[ Laughter ]
"Sierra Mist."
[ Dance music plays ]
[ Air horns ]
[ Laughter ]
-"Dr. Pepper."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
They're all
named after soft drinks?
Hey, did you guys hear about
the Mercedes recall?
It's not good, dude.
Check this out.
-An important recall alert
to tell you about this morning,
as Mercedes-Benz sounds the
alarm over 124,000 vehicles
whose sunroofs might suddenly
snap off while driving.
-Oh, man!
I just bought a Mercedes-Benz.
-Oh, really? Geez,
I'm sorry about that Tariq.
-It's okay. I still have
my trusty Volkswagen Beetle,
so I'm all good.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-"Oh," what?
-Roll the clip.
-Here's an important recall
alert for drivers this morning.
Volkswagen recalling
nearly 40,000 of its Beetles
because of faulty airbags.
Inflators can explode with too
much force and hurl shrapnel.
-What?!
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that -- that's not good.
-How am I supposed
to get around this week?
-You don't have any other way?
-I mean,
I have an old four-wheeler.
I guess I could dust off
my Polaris Sportsman
and Scrambler 1000 S
all-terrain vehicle.
-Polaris is recalling
the Sportsman
and Scrambler 1000 S
all-terrain vehicles.
-Come on!
-I'm -- I'm sorry, Tariq.
There's gotta be something
you can do.
-No.
N-No, Jimmy.
I'm just gonna stay at home
and sit back and enjoy
some Member's Mark holiday
m-macarons sold at Sam's Club.
-A consumer alert for you --
Member's Mark
holiday m-macarons
sold at Sam's Club
are being recalled.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This January is a bust!
-There's gotta be something
you can do.
-Well, is anything safe?
I'm gonna have to go
buy groceries in Kansas
and only eat Sunsprouts --
[ Swallows ] -- from now on.
-We have a recall alert.
If you buy groceries in Kansas,
Sunsprouts -- [ Swallows ] --
is recalling 1,400 pounds
of alfalfa sprouts.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's it.
That's it, man.
I'm locking myself inside,
just me and my washing machine,
safe from all problems
and potential "janjer."
-A washing machine recall.
The problem
and the potential "janjer."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So close.
[ Both laugh ]
So close.
-Yeah.
-Stay out of --
Tariq Trotter doesn't want to
get any "janjer" over there.
Tariq Trotter.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, guys, I read that surgeons
are warning against
leg-lengthening surgery...
[ Laughter ]
...a procedure that has become
popular with men.
Yeah, it's very expensive.
In order to get approved
by your insurance company,
you have to prove that nobody
is swiping right on your Tinder.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to experts,
the friendliest city in the U.S.
is Honolulu.
Unfortunately, since "aloha"
also means goodbye,
Honolulu is also
the least friendliest city.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We have a great show tonight!